this video is sponsored by the leading
password manager
dashlane find out more later in the
video
hey 42 here rn jesus
a portmanteau of the initialism rng
which stands for random number
generation and
jesus which stands for the son of god
is a light-hearted deity in gamer
culture
so named because random outcomes based
on random number generation
play a large part in many modern games
whether it's the impact of a card effect
in hearthstone
the exact power-up you're awarded in
mario kart or the particular layout of
your shiny new world in minecraft
sometimes rn jesus is on your side and
you crush your opponents with laughable
ease
and sometimes he isn't and you turn off
your computer in a fit of fury
before throwing your controller at the
wall but
i have a question for you when do you
think the first random number generator
was invented
any guesses by talking about rng in the
context of computer games
i was hoping to trick you into guessing
something relatively recent
and definitely digital age but random
number generation is much
much much older than that in fact
the first random number generators ever
made predate
recorded human history of course i'm no
longer talking about the random number
generators in computer games that come
under the
questionable control of the great puppet
master rn jesus
but about the kind of simple mechanical
random number generators
that are so common in the modern world
we don't even really think of them as
random number generators at all
dice have you ever wondered why dice
have dots on their sides
instead of numbers well that's because
when humans first crafted
dice written numbers hadn't been
invented yet
and we've never bothered to update the
design bone dice found on the scottish
island of orkney
may be more than 5 000 years old
and similarly aged dice have been
uncovered in iran
iraq and india aside from being rather
crudely fashioned
most of these findings were remarkably
similar to the dice
we still use today as well as bearing a
striking resemblance to modern dice
we used those early versions in much the
same way we still use them today
to generate random numbers in games of
chance
but why do we need external tools to
generate random numbers in the first
place
can't we just make them up ourselves
well
it turns out we humans are to put it
mildly
apocalyptically awful at generating
random numbers
and you don't even need a complicated
experiment to prove it
in a simple survey of eight and a half
thousand college students
who were asked to name a number from one
to ten
a whopping twenty-eight percent said
seven
whilst only two percent said 10
which is about as random as deafened
taxes
most of the time this kind of innate
human predictability
is pretty harmless the kind of
psychological quirk
magicians have been exploiting for
decades to convince us they're reading
our minds
but it can have far more serious
consequences
during the second world war german code
clerks had to select
three random letters to position the
enigma machine's rotors
at the start of each new message despite
being given a set of instructions on how
to ensure these selections were random
the clerks failed miserably often using
the initials of family members or other
similarly predictable configurations
and that may seem like a small slip up
after all the enigma machine had 159
quintillion possible settings but it
proved to be a crucial part of the
allies eventually breaking enigma
which is thought to have shortened the
war by as much as two years
and saved millions of lives in the
process
another tool that is nothing short of a
lifesaver
is dashlane's industry-leading password
manager
and all-in-one security suite dashlane
creates super strong and unique
passwords
for all your online accounts and also
fills them
so you never have to click forgot
password ever again
and you don't have to sweat about the
extremely rare chance that dashlane
could be breached
because dashlane safely stores and
decrypts your data
on your local device only using your
master password
this means that dashlane never has
access to your personal data
and any hacker would only see random
noise dashlane also
autofills your credit card information
whilst online shopping
so you can make purchases without having
to fetch your wallet
dashlane has a built-in vpn to encrypt
your data
and keep your online activity anonymous
best of all it works on any device
whether you're protecting classified
documents or random videos of your cat
there's no better way to make your
online world impenetrable
than by using dashlane from my honest
experience dashlane is the best
all bases covered security and time
saving tool out there
as we'll learn in this video many
internet security systems
are based on random number generation
and dashlane knows that better than most
but there's nothing at all random about
how dashlane protects you
it just works to keep your passwords and
data secure
24 7 while saving you time online and
making your life
easier i highly recommend trying
dashlane for free
on your first device which you can do so
by heading to
www.dashlane.com
forward slash 42 then if you decide you
want to upgrade to premium
use my code 42 for 10
off don't miss it despite this seemingly
fundamental flaw in our ability to
ever truly be random random number
generation wasn't particularly high up
on humanity's
to-do list until very recently we
just didn't really need it with our
requirement for randomness being almost
entirely confined
to the world of games and gambling up
until the 20th century
however it was around that time that
scientists and statisticians
began to recognize the value of
randomness for use in making
fairer experiments and in the creation
of truly representative statistics
among several other things which is why
in 1927 a statistician called leonard
tippett published the world's first
large-scale collection
of random numbers being a series of 40
000 numbers listed one after the other
it was hardly what you'd call a page
turner but it was a big step forward for
randomness all the same
others soon followed suit and within the
space of a few years
there were a whole host of different
random number sets to choose from
but there was a problem the numbers in
these tables
weren't really random at all
as i said we humans suck at being random
so tippet and co had to look for
external sources of randomness when
building their tables
tipit sampled data from the 1925 census
whilst others based their versions on
data sources like
logarithm tables and even the telephone
directory
the numbers they came up with certainly
appeared to be pretty well jumbled up
but they weren't truly random in a
statistical sense
because the data used to generate them
wasn't random
either and the funny thing is in the
almost 100 years since
tipit's tables were first published the
problem of our random numbers
not being quite random enough has never
completely gone away
and that's important because with the
rise of computers
random numbers once just humanity's bit
of fun on the side
are now absolutely vital to modern life
specifically in the field of
cryptography which just so happens
to underpin security online it isn't an
exaggeration to say that if we fail to
make our random numbers random enough
the internet as we know it will cease to
function
without random numbers internet banking
would be impossible as would any form of
e-commerce
and pretty much anything else that
involves the use of sensitive data
and that's pretty worrying because today
we mostly use
computers as our source of randomness
and whilst they aren't as bad as people
at generating random numbers
they're still pretty bad at it that's
because computers are fundamentally
deterministic machines if you ask them
the same question
over and over again they'll give you the
same answer every single time
that's fantastic for pretty much
everything we ask our computers to do
running programs computing complicated
problems
pretending we're working when in reality
we're on our fifth straight hour
lost in a youtube vortex but not so
great for generating random numbers
computers do what they're told and they
can only generate a random number
if we first tell them how to do so the
how in this case is typically something
called a prng
or a pseudo-random number generator
which is an algorithm that takes an
initial input or
seed value and manipulates it in various
ways
in order to generate a sequence of
random numbers that
appear to be random hence the name
pseudo random but wait a minute
what's the difference between numbers
that appear to be random
and numbers that actually are random
i'm glad you asked because that's a very
good question prngs create sequences of
numbers that are random in the sense
that
they bear no statistical relationship to
one another
take a nice big sample and you'll have
roughly as many sevens
as tens and no discernible pattern will
emerge
give someone a list of pseudo-random
numbers and they'll have no way of
knowing which number is coming up next
but these numbers
aren't truly random because anyone who
knows both the seed value
which can sometimes be your computer's
clock and the steps taken by the
algorithm to generate the sequence
would be able to calculate which number
was coming up next
with a hundred percent accuracy and
if your sequence is predictable it isn't
truly random in every sense of the word
that might sound like semantics but it's
actually a crucial difference
for lots of use cases including those
presided over by our
occasional ally and regular nemesis rn
jesus
pseudo random numbers are just fine
statistical randomness is all you really
need here
because that will ensure your game
behaves the way it should
but imagine you were able to predict the
random numbers from a prng
dictating which cards you were being
dealt during a game of online poker
you'd be posting snaps of your shiny new
lambo to insta
in no time and then of course
there's internet security random numbers
are used in cryptography for all sorts
of things
including both secure key and nonce
generation
which are crucial components and
security online
responsible for the reassuring little
padlock in your browser
that lets you know your jesus shaped
dorito ebay shopping spree
is encrypted if a passing hacker is able
to predict these numbers
they could break the kinds of encryption
that keep your data
safe forget winning a few hands of texas
hold'em
with that kind of information you would
effectively become
god of the internet able to access
pretty much
anything you felt like by the way to any
british viewers watching this
in cryptography nonces are arbitrary
numbers that are generated and used only
once
and then discarded i haven't suddenly
started talking about sex offenders
just wanted to clear that up before you
clicked report
the thing is as you might have noticed
seeing as you're watching this video
right now
the internet as we know it is doing just
fine at the moment
e-commerce has not failed internet
banking still seems to work
and whilst jeff bezos might seem like
the god of the internet
he doesn't have direct access to your
bank account
probably the reason the internet hasn't
collapsed around us is that
when it really counts we can actually do
better than
pseudo random number generation yes
ladies and gentlemen we can go
full random but you might be wondering
how since neither
us humans or our computer buddies are up
to the job
when leonard tippett brought his
best-selling number table to the market
he ultimately failed in his quest for
randomness
because the source he used to generate
his numbers the 1925 census
wasn't random to begin with but
luckily for us there are excellent
sources of truly random information
out there if you know where to look for
them and no i'm not talking about my
youtube channel
but it would be a good place to start
good sources of
on tap true randomness include
atmospheric noise
cosmic background radiation the
photoelectric effect
and radioactive decay amongst many
others
the great thing about some of these
phenomena is that they are
in theory at least random as a
fundamental level
meaning even if we had the technology to
understand everything about the system
in question
the position and velocity of every
single particle
we still wouldn't be able to predict
what was going to happen
next you can't hack into the radioactive
decay of uranium
no matter your budget or expertise
by measuring signal fluctuations in
sources like these
we're able to generate truly random
sequences of numbers
that not only pass statistical pattern
tests for randomness
but are also literally impossible to
predict
because they're generated by physical
processes that
are intrinsically unpredictable
for internet security that's about as
watertight as it gets
now that might sound like the end of the
story but there's a twist
because even truly random numbers come
with problems
the kinds of processes they're based on
are typically difficult
to accurately measure meaning
observational biases can be introduced
if you aren't careful they're also prone
to failing slightly meaning your random
numbers can
sneakily stop being random when you
aren't looking
these kinds of challenges can be
overcome with clever engineering
and monitoring but there's one problem
there's simply no getting around volume
you can think of true random number
generators are sort of like
farmers harvesting randomness from the
world around us
but just like with real crops sometimes
the supply doesn't meet the demand
that means true random number generators
typically output numbers
much slower than pseudo-random number
generators
and if you ask your trng for more random
numbers than there is
available entropy in the system it's
measuring
it's liable to tell you to bugger off
and come back later
okay so prngs aren't secure enough and
trngs aren't practical enough
we're basically screwed then right
thankfully
not quite because whilst prngs and trngs
are both
a little off csprngs
are the proverbial porridge that's just
right
for those of you who forgot to revise
your obscure internet
based acronyms before today's video
csprngs are
cryptographically secure pseudorandom
number generators
and they basically take the best bits
from both true random number generators
and pseudo-random number generators to
create a happy compromise
csprngs are based on algorithms in much
the same way as prngs
but with one crucial difference they
typically use an
external physical source of randomness
when generating the initial seed value
so whilst the sequence of random numbers
is generated procedurally by an
algorithm
the seed value is truly random
and therefore in theory unguessable
it's the ideal combination of security
and practicality even so internet
security is a tricky business
and sometimes mistakes are made back in
hackers were able to exploit a bug in
the random number generator
used in android-based bitcoin wallets
with the result
that huge quantities of bitcoins were
stolen directly from the owner's
accounts
almost overnight and sometimes it isn't
only the bad guys who are looking to
exploit possible weaknesses in random
number generation systems
back in 2006 the dual elliptic curve
deterministic random bits generator
was approved as cryptographically secure
by the national institute of standards
and technology
and endorsed by both the american
national standards institute and
iso but over the years rumors began to
circulate about possible flaws in the
algorithm
namely that it contained a secret
backdoor allowing the nsa to break
any encryption based on its random
numbers
that may sound like exactly the kind of
conspiracy theory people make fun of in
polite conversation
but in 2013 the new york times connected
memos leaked by ed snowden to the case
suggesting this one might actually be
true
and that the nsa effectively had
unfiltered access to supposedly secure
systems
used by millions of people in the us
and beyond though it was never proven
either way the random number generator
in question was quietly withdrawn from
service in 2014
after some seven years in operation
that's about all for today
but before i go i thought it would be
fitting to end things with a quick
prayer to the man who made this video
possible
rn jesus please bow your heads
rn jesus who art and procedurally
generated heaven
hallowed be thy ability to screw me over
thy random numbers come thy
unpredictable will be done
in hearthstone as it is in destiny
give us this day our daily loot boxes
and forgive us our rage quits
as we forgive those who rage quit
against us for thine is the maddening
variability
the arbitrary and the nonsense
forever and ever are met
thanks for watching and thanks again to
dashlane for sponsoring this video
head to dashlane.com forward slash 42 to
try it for free
on your first device